I warmly welcome you to arthur schopenhauer,
one of the most important
thinkers of the nineteenth century, and of
all philosophers, schopenhauer was and is
the best and most brilliant
pessimist
so furiously
described
his main work the world as will and
imagination is still a
provocation
because it represents the thesis that
man is ultimately not like
everyone says a homo sapiens is a
spiritual being a rational being no he
says people only appear to be
from the beginning  actually being pulled
but being pushed from behind
similar to plants or
animals, we humans are also pushed from behind,
so to speak, by a clock
driving the famous will to live and
he says in this context that we
can easily recognize this will to live
if we look at it
everyone looks closely  living beings if
you are trying to kill them go into the
highest possible resistance and
do everything to somehow
stay alive
i quote the whole nature of a living being threatened in such a way
that it
immediately turns into desperate resistance and
resisting death
you can see, for example, the unbelievable fear  of a
person in mortal danger and the
boundless jubilation after his rescue
the will this will to live which
we see in the fact that everyone wants to stay alive
this will is universal, which means it
is also
in the fly that is hanging in the spider's web
and trying with all your might  to
get out of the spider's web
like in a hare who can only do
it faster than that and tries
to escape the fox and also in
the person who, let's say,
sees an avalanche coming towards him and tries
to reach the forest from the side faster
to avoid the avalanche in
to bring safety
it is the same universal as and or
even if you bite  For example, who of you
has a garden if you
rip out rubbish then it's right
back there so it's about the
plants and everyone also knows the picture
of a dandelion cutting through the middle of
a tarmac path or a cobblestone
path, ladies and
gentlemen  is the blind will to live
and schopenhauer can therefore say every
look at the world testifies that the will
to live is the only commodity expression of your
innermost being and this will
to live says schopenhauer is
metaphysical that means that the will
to live is metaphysical from the
greek meter  that means behind and
physically quasi-physically
physically the will to live is to be looked for behind
all physical and
physical phenomena
an example so this metaphysical
will is not measurable
yes and an example we could use
appropriate sensitive equipment to
measure how much force the fly has
tried and could escape in the spider web
n say they put 0.003 seven
kilos upon tyne in the surcharges the
hare runs away from the fox at 38 kilometers per hour
or even the human let's say
it manages to reach 30 kilometers
soon the avalanche cent
is coming that we could measure the basic structure that they all have in
common  but the will
the will to live which as
its reason is metaphysically the reason
why everyone moves and runs like
this we can no longer measure it itself
because it is metaphysically good the will
alone is and changeable and absolutely
identical while so to speak each
living beings have different speeds
, etc.
, the will always remains the same and is at work in
every living being with the full,
undivided
power and the theologians and theologians and
philosophers are wrong
because they have simply overlooked the blind will
and man is not a spirit being and
also  no rational being
instead so it's the blind will
appear  en as a life drive
lust for life and courage for life
but why does copenhagen actually speak
of blind will because after all,
survival is definitely a sensible
goal yes or also reproduction in
teterow and at first glance one
could think the will is quite
purposeful he says schopenhauer
alone  on closer inspection
we will also find here that it is rather
a blind urge, a completely groundless,
unmotivated drive and that is
why, on closer inspection, it is
unmotivated this drive because it
does not serve a higher purpose and that is the
interesting thing, this survival serves
a higher purpose and there  asks
schopenhauer but the ultimate goal of
all what is he to keep plagued individuals for
a short period of time
then the reproduction of this
generation and its doings with
this obvious disproportion
between the
and the wage the will to live appears to us
as a fool a delusion so the
medium is  t a mere gate wasn't a kind
because it doesn't serve any higher purpose
and it's for three reasons it's blind
so firstly it serves it's blind because in the
end as much as we all keep
on living and weaving through it
ultimately we all have to die
secondly it's  blind will because
even if you say okay but we're going
to have children we'll plant and
straight away woopen said h that's
ultimately transplanting the
sex drive is blind willi because his
pessimistic prognosis is that in the
end the sex drive will lead to the complete
overpopulation of the entire planet
thirdly, the will is blind and that is
perhaps the most important thing because it does
n't reflect on
itself it doesn't recognize itself and you can see that
especially when the will individual
whose word from schopenhauer the will
goes into the individual
rows and individuality itself in
basically, and the following is happening now, the
same will that the wolf a  drives
that he absolutely catches and kills the deer
and can eat it
, but that he, like many individuals, is
also in the re and drives it deer
to somehow escape the fatal bite
and there Schopenhauer says in a
so therefore don't say Schopenhauer
in one of his appearances  so wolf looking for
increased well-being in the
other on
the right causes great suffering and so in a violent urge puts his teeth into
his own flesh not knowing
that he only ever hurts himself
so the will hammers its teeth into
its own flesh and because he is
blind knows  not at all that a reason
is self-
rival therefore schopenhauer can
say the source and the tormented are 1 in
addition the blind man wants him of
course without any
morals so he knows no scruples
that is why joe bauer comes to the conclusion
the will is 300 considered himself
knowledge loose and only a blind
unstoppable therefore also the
majestic lion we s
always so admired for many centuries and they
have been described so well in literature
because it has such serenity
and calm but the sac
tropenhaus also ultimately stands on
a mountain of corpses and
only maintains its existence through a daily new
toll of blood and ultimately  there is no
escape from this eating and being
eaten because all living beings
are metabolisms that know
inhale and exhale they have to eat they have to
drink and that's why when
you look at nature you can say
just look at this world constantly
needy beings who just because of that  that
they eat each other up for a while get through
their existence in fear and hardship
until they finally fall to death
like indians that existence shopmacher draws the same conclusion
as the buddhists that existence
means suffering living means suffering and
so he can say that every
life story is like that  a story of suffering
that saw life as a whole
in addition a sweet you say quite
sad trend he also says the path is
steadily downhill these electrons
childhood happy youth
arduous manhood that no
misprint so he writes in this
spelling the arduous manhood
the frail often wretched circles
do and finally the agony
sees it  not exactly as
if existence were a misstep and
Schopenhauer's clear answer is yes,
existence is actually a misstep,
an accident of evolution and we have
to admit that we have to be happy about the existence of
the world and not that
its existence is not preferable to its existence
Would that be, ladies and gentlemen,
now we are unfortunately or how should I put it
sadder ugly are we all there or
still there although our existence is
actually not going to be
preferable to ours are we all there
but I can them yes I can them
now  not consoling but
schopenhauer also gives us at the very end  h three
chances and explains to us three
possibilities how we can escape the blind will
and the suffering in the world
but first we look again at
his main work the world as will and
introduction this book begins with
a very clear and very simple
sentence
the world  is my imagination is the
first sentence here and that is of course
already a provocation
because if the world is just my
imagination then maybe i have an
idea of the world but in reali
y it is completely different and this
entence by schopenhauer is exactly like that
meaning the only
world that everyone really knows and of
which he knows it somehow carries itself as
his imagination
i'll give you an example of the
woodcutter the woodworker who goes far
and has to cut down the huge tree he
sees the tree in his imagination
the one whole  different ideas of
the tree if he knows i have to
fall now like the children
climbing up there
d  You experience the tree in a completely different way and
they experience it in a different way than the
lovers I kiss under the tree
maybe even love them they see this
foliage we have a completely
different idea of one and the same tree
here
ore Schopenhauer can say that in the same
urroundings it is still alive  everyone is in
a different world because everything
that is there for people is only there in
their consciousness is precisely why
these sentences you may have
ideas or an even more common
sentence that we hear what kind of world
you live in and basically we have
already all in the same world but with the
same environment we all
imagined others and that also applies to
science because in
science too there are ideas of
the world
first they had the idea that the
earth is flat then it
suddenly said it is and then  it's the
is the center of the universe
all around are the stars no no we
circle ourselves un  d the sun
we are at the edge of the universe and everything
is relative and with every new
idea and every new hypothesis
our entire reality
that we know from the world changes and the
only certainty we all have in
our lives is the only
real certainty  that we are
driven by blind waves and
why because they they there he wants it
we get it through a two-fold
idea of our body we all have
body and we ha
e two different ideas of our body one a
an idea
n a more intelligent perce
tion as  object among objects then but
at the same time in a completely different way,
namely as will that means when you
get up in the morning and look in the
mirror, look down at yourself and
the cupboard is on the right and the chest of drawers on the
left, then you first have an
idea of yourself  as a completely
normal object under objects
there is the closet object there  s chest of drawers
object there is my body
project and then you can say okay it’s that
heavy i’m too fat it doesn’t matter
but we see ourselves as an object
compared to the closet the eyes weight
is hopefully heavier and
we still have a second idea of
dy and that  is the
crucial one we feel
that we are hungry that we are thirsty then
that we have needy
needs senses that and he knows everyone in
himself about this idea is not
deceptive
this idea shows us how the
world is made
and that's why he can say  everyone
finds themselves as this will in which
the inner being of the world consists and there
is that would be the first
summary of his main work, so to speak, there
are 100 different
ideas of the world but behind
everything there is a universal
metaphysical will and that is that
decisive is therefore also the name of the world
as will and representation in this
series  follow
and because it is the case that the will
drives us, there are 1 6-fold slides
from which we cannot get out because we have
already said to live means to suffer
and I will start right away first of
all wanting arises from
need, i.e. from lack, i.e. from suffering  against
a wish that is fulfilled
at least ten remain denied
so with this first suffering
simply meant our need structure because
you know yes if we are
hungry for example that is a lack
we suffer from the lack of
food when we are thirsty and the second
problem is it  says we ca
n't satisfy all needs yes because
for example need for love
need for recognition for world fame
for power for money for material
security for eternal health we
have so much need himself that he
can say
ten more remain fails the next
second major problems with the  we suffer
is that these desires
these needs always w  everyone comes
so we have maybe that's why we're
always in the supermarket and have to do
and do yes if you keep coming back
the needs and said
others have already said yes but
schopenhauer that's just nice
that we keep getting hungry because of that
we have  new pleasures again and again
that's great about life and
pleasure outweighs all effort and
schopenhauer says whoever makes the assertion that pleasure outweighs pain in
the world
or at least
wants to check the scales in a nutshell can only compare the
feeling  of an animal that has
another period with that of this other the
third major point of suffering that we all have
here in life and also that
condemns us the will to live is the
individual that i have already
mentioned because the will is actually in all
living beings it comes naturally
there is always
a fight between living beings he says we see
nature everywhere  quarrel battle and change
of victory each level of the objective
zion of the will he
disputes the matter the space the time for others so
for example every objective nation
each level of the objective zion what
are the levels of the objective zion for
example plants the animals the people
are  different levels of objective
zion and each power of the other
plants suck the matter in dispute from
the earth which by the way is also willing to
get the minerals out and make those
who dispute the minerals eat the animals
then graze half of them again and
dispute the matter there  and
also among each other so within the
plants schopenhauer has the example
that plants often reach for the sun
cover another one that
no longer has sun and goes
1 there too everyone is fighting each other over the
matter and the worst thing would
be the worst of course the
human being  namely there also had a
nice sentence he says the man
has  all others suppressed and they were brought to the
mere factory
it was not nice i think i
brought it with me so that the will to live is
its own food throughout in various forms until the end the
human race because it overwhelms all others
nature for a product
to its own  use sees the same
sex but also itself that
struggle that self-dividing of the will
revealed to the most terrible clarity
and homo homini lupus is so first
he also talks about the fact that we lock the
plants in glass
prisons i.e. greenhouses that we
lock the animals in huge halls but
man also becomes a wolf to man
homo homini lupus
thomas hobbes quoted the english philosopher
because we and he brings special
examples and describes them beautifully
these factories of the industrial
revolution in which he lived and
writes monotonous worker things
movement i  n the whole day in a
hall without any light without sunshine
and that he says is degrading and
pure exploitation of
slavery but this is the fate of
millions ultimately this mutual
oppression exploitation and
cannibalization is the result of
our need for structure and there
is no way out  because the will is a
hungry will
because there is no way out because the
will is a hungry will yes and
he now shows that in a very large
number of meticulous examples there
are even spiders that
decorate the male partner after the act of love
or insects they write  lay their
eggs in other animals and the penalties
hatch and eat the living
thing from the inside or turtles land every year to lay eggs
and the jackals are already waiting, twisting open
the soft breastplate
and eating them alive and everyone
finds this misery  year instead I told you
now only a
really  I brought a touching example
because it shows again the blind will that
shows itself individually as soon as he is in a
unit he
fights completely without thinking in this
individual unit and the example
is the bulldog ant a huge
brown evil ant which means evil is of
course nonsense  is not a
moral judgment
and he says if you cut them
through a fight starts
between the head and the tail part
that attacks it with its teeth
and it defends itself bravely by
stabbing on that one until they die or are
dragged away by the other ants
and it  finds every time
thousands of years of observations of nature, also
by natural scientists at the time,
incorporated
the fourth major suffering that we have as a result of our
existence on earth is a
specifically human suffering, namely
the concern for future
needs we also have that, the animal
does not know which animal  for example
no worries or none  fear of
poverty in old age knows you less
but the person who just has his
needs under control he always
has thoughts of the next
needs and in contrast to the animal
the animal lives in the present
precisely this animals own complete
absorption in the present  much
to the joy that we have with our
pets the
home has poodles with us on the long
walks and it was just good
that at least if he
drank a satisfied meal then
he is calm and happy like him
people who are already thinking about their future
hunger
there is also the fact that in
this fourth quarter we always have to
think about the future we always have a
main concern it is also interesting
that is true I actually thought about
it i also always have a
main concern and he says
when a great
worry that oppresses us is finally lifted from our breasts by the happy ending  will
soon be replaced by another,
yes, and even if it is smaller, he
says, then build herself up until she
takes the throne again,
you can, yes, and the fifth long because
the fifth election, which we all
have to put up with here  interestingly, as humans it
starts
or this suffering starts when
we've just managed
to satisfy all
our needs it's boredom take a look at a
family man who has really taken care of himself
has made 20 30 million can take care of himself for the rest of his
life  best
medical care everything and for his
wife and for the children and for the
grandchildren what happened there during the campaign
shed hair literally
the bird of prey of boredom here and how long it
is so bad because
either we are in need or we are
bored yes  so that behind
the need there is immediately boredom, which
even affects the smarter animals is
a consequence of that  life has no
true real content if life would
call content then that would
n't be a problem at all then we would
n't be afraid of boredom because then it
would be very nice but
boredom is very dangerous because we then
feel
it you don't see it anymore  distracted by
the need and the errands yes and the occupation
we are not distracted
and then we feel the whole lesson of
existence and that the whole hustle and bustle is
actually for no purpose and the
higher animals have it too and in
fact there are all the
cities  zoos run this
problem the animals
don't have to remember if they
no longer hunt no longer have to run away bring themselves to
safety from predators vice versa no
longer hunt the
degenerate we become obese
depressed and
mortality is actually very high in zoos
because the animal also generates them and it
cannot create them properly if they
do these  r will to live is so reduced
because food is always
brought to them and they are in their fence they are
a complete security yes
schopenhauer writes people are often afraid
of these holes in employment
that is why they always make
artificial full appointment calendars
so that they  yes, always have employment
and look for constant employment
but as soon as this stops, the
entire karl hyde and teaching of
existence comes to light and the last great
suffering the sixth great suffering of
man is mortality and thus
the irrefutable fact that
life is only continuously inhibited
dying is an always open-minded death
and so we all live constantly
towards death at every moment and yes it
would be sad it would be
evening again schopenhauer says every
evening we think we have a day poorer and the
children are still
unclear  writes schopenhauer sitting like in
a theater by the great r  oten velvet
curtain full of curiosity and
waiting for this curtain to finally
open full of wishes and thirst for action and
sit in front of it curiously
and that’s what Schopenhauer says it’s lucky
that we don’t know what’s really going to
happen and young people also say of
course push death backwards and
see  the ones that aren't there yet he writes
the cheerfulness and courage of our
youth is partly based on the fact that we
walk uphill and don't even see death
because it's at the foot of the other side of the
mountain but even at the age of 36
everyone climbs the peak
and gradually  first completely
and clearly but gradually he sees
more and more clearly at the foot of the mountain what
is waiting for him and he compares he has
an annual metaphorical language he also
compares the individual biographies of
the people with ships that set sail at the beginning
and go out under full
sail  out of the harbor and to conquer the world
to find the princess treasure
further  to capture and
to discover life for oneself
but as schopenhauer usually does
, every shipwrecked person finally runs home and is
disempowered in the harbor
but then it doesn't matter whether he was
happy or unhappy in
a life that is now over
and so in conclusion we are
doomed to suffer sixfold we suffer
from our needs we suffer from the fact
that they keep coming we
suffer from the individuation of
the will that forces us to cannibalize
and we suffer from the future concern which
we always have our main concern
and of course also from  the fact that
we all have to die again what
overshadows our life but that is not
only our personal life is
also overshadowed
world history history shows us the life of the
peoples and finds nothing
to tell but wars and revolts the peaceful
years decide only appear as
short  pauses so world history also
shows us w  Always this blind
will as a fight and it gets even
worse he says clearly there are such
and there are wars and
science at that time already tried to get
a grip on bacteriology and everything that
kind of
says there were already first successes  he
even if one were to
assume optimistically that at some point there would be
no more such wars and no wars
yes even if he says it would all be useless yes assuming
all this would
finally be overcome and eliminated the result
would be the overpopulation of the
entire planet in the end  whose
dreadful evil can now only
be
visualized by a bold imagination and there is
also no progress in
history
because there are always individual
scientists and wise people who
recognize and say the right thing, but that
is also of no use
in general the wise ones all have
always said the same thing and the
gates that means the u  a measurable
majority of all times we have always
done the same thing, namely exactly the opposite
and that's how it will always be
we're all laughing now but unfortunately here
i think it
touched me a little bit because it's
also a dizzying
topicality when you  let's assume that we are
actually now feeling the consequences of the
overpopulation of the planet that says yes
he doesn't say about population but
population now
huge streams of migration every day like
a 50 football field rainforest are
cleaned up everything becomes monocultures
agriculture is intensified the
insects die so i want to  I do
n't even know where it's going to
practice this I don't want to imagine yes says
and there were also wise people who
recognized that already in the 70s exactly in
1972 came this big study from the club of
rome the limits of growth at that time
there were 3,  7 million billion citizens
and the club of rome said  we
have to limit economic growth
and the engine of this growth is the
population explosion so a super
exponential population development
and we must not go over four billion under any circumstances
we have to do programs to educate
the population everywhere and
get hold of it yes and this book
was in  30 languages and me still so trans
ated in the world was celebrated and every
hing but you know yourself the stalk and 7
billion they
ll did exactly the opposite as sc
openhauer says yes and according to predi
tions we will soon even be ten billi
n and y
u would like to see them  bad really
can't imagine the coming to us that's
why schopenhauer comes to
the conclusion that the commodity philosophy of
history consists in the insight
that with all the
endless changes one always has the
same same and changeable being
before one so is a
pessimistic assessment because he
doesn't think  for the purpose of  from hegel that
history is in progress and we learn
from generation to generation
and everything is getting better and better no there is
no progress recognizable now he
asks himself the question yes why
then there is all this hustle and bustle on
earth why is it happening at all there
said  why the whole horrific
scene is the only answer so
objectified the will says
more we can't determine
but people are not
satisfied with that man has such a
metaphysical need for explanation
temples and churches pagodas and mosques
in all countries testify to
metaphysical  human
need we have always been looking for an explanation and
the koran and the bible say action
fulfills exactly this need and is
exactly the same as schopenhauer because
they both promise eternal life
and say you never die could
live forever and the whole world is
doing this  here with all the suffering and
problems said that  is just a test
and whoever passes the test will be rewarded by
god who organized and created this world and the tests
with eternal life yes and that says the
dandruff hair
these explanations all have a
theodicy problem theodicy from the
Greek theo god and it is called im
greek justification so all
theologians must do theodicy
that means a justification of god with
regard to why god if he is an
almighty loving god also
created the suffering
natural disasters himself such the
wars all these things why does he have
all power and all validity in his  create all this
and the theologians have to
justify it and they do it in
a theodicy the most important
theodicy we have is that of
leibnitz you know you maybe says everything well
god is responsible
for it and in his omnipotence
actually made the diseases
and  the wars and even you
created the possibility that man
can orientate himself towards evil and show
moral
misconduct but says leibniz you can
justify that because that is still
the best of a theoretically possible world
he could not have invented it better
than just the disease
gives us the joy of health
only war lets us make
peace and only the
possibility of moral misconduct yes also creates
this miracle that we can be
good and be happy about our good and
that is why god created this world the
way it has it
ultimately create the best of all possible worlds
even if suffering has
developed and i don't need to
count them installation schopenhauer is of
course very violent and says it's
not the best it's even the
worst of all possible worlds
now this world is set up to be
more precise  not being able to pass it
would only be a little bad  r
so it could no longer exist
so a tick worse still 1 50 ever
everything collapses well so every
theodicy must fail according to Schopenhauer
and he brings eg also a nice
argument he says if you actually explain life and
the whole suffering here
as one  test of god or
also as a punishment of god
then you have to
answer the question why the loving god also
punishes the animals so damn hard
yes because the animals have to
go along with everything
and ultimately he says if god is
actually almighty then he is
also damned
actually for this suffering and that's why he
likes the hindu
creation story so much because
the world
happened to him because the creator god brahmann accidentally he
stumbled then the world fell out of
him yes and it pleases
schopenhauer wants there says the bremen
brings through a kind of worship  but the
world remains
to atone for it until he  got rid of
it very well
yes he likes it of course but
unfortunately he finds our i'll
tell you the
creation story in the old testament in the evening
even worse he says
but such a god who
brings forth this world of hardship and misery and
then even himself  applause applauds
and says everything was very good first book
moses 131 that is unbearable and
then of course also rejected
all the descriptions of hell
and heaven
the best description of what was found
has schopenhauer says there is still that
of dante alighieri he has that  Written a
book like that,
the comedy, the Viennese divina commedia,
where he, so to speak, spread out all the
details of hell and the torments of hell
and Schopenhauer said yes, if you
read through it and do it,
you will see very quickly that he copied all of this
from people, yes, where from
because aunt took the material to its
height differently than from this our
real world and  but it has become
quite a decent hell and
now comes but now said but then
at the end he describes the sky and
thought only a few pages brought
together logically because
our world doesn't offer any materials
like that then he
actually only has a few than  the
church fathers are quoted to give any
hints heaven could be good but if the
religions ultimately cannot give an answer
the question arises
what
is all the hustle and bustle on earth for
?
tragic comedy there is not
remotely foreseeable
our only answer is this is how
the will to live is objectified
and now, as promised, there are
three possibilities and chances how we can free
ourselves from the blind will and
all the suffering
yes and the first way out is this  art
when we stand in front of a work of art and immerse
ourselves completely in the sc  put the beauty of a painting of
a city or a work of
art into it and enjoy the pure beauty
then we are distracted for this time
and catapulted out of
our own constant
need and therefore our want therefore he
can say this state is pure
contemplation getting lost in the contemplation
forgetting the object  of all
individuality
so we forget our ego we are
completely in the art value and he formulated it a
bit like kant that is
pleasure without interest so if
you go to the exhibition in
a museum
then you basically leave your
needs behind there are pictures hanging like
you can't go there and
eat one Rembrandt after the other you can't eat
and then the Schopenhauer of the
need says that we
want to look at the art
that's a very special need
that's no longer the blind person wants yes there he
says we are  for that moment
of despicable will dr  angs rid we
celebrate the sabbath of the penitentiary work
of wanting the wheel of the upsilon stands
still
so we celebrate the
sabbath of the disciplined work of wanting that means we
celebrate freedom during the week
we always have the whole wanting drives us
dublin ii wants but if we do that
let's look at the work of art and celebrate the
sunday off from the blind will,
so to speak, and the wheel of the ypsilon stands
still
that comes out of the crisis
mythology king seeon was so daring
here to seduce the woman of two to
naturally noticed and
punished him with a rotating
bound to the wheel of fire that is the wheel of the ypsilon and
in this parable in this
parable we humans are all bound to the wheel to
the wheel of fire of the blind will yes but in the enjoyment of
art this
is first there is a short second
chance is the music the music
works there  but in a different way
the music is a reflection of the will
itself that is why the effect of the music is
s  o much more powerful and
penetrating than that of the other
artists, so the music has a
moving effect on us because it is the
direct image of the blind will,
because in music
we have highs, lows, middle tones, we have drama,
then everything collapses, then builds
up again and that is exactly our
life but in which we can be heard it is
no longer our own life but
we also take part in
something else here
so we our ego fortunately saves itself for the
time of enjoying the music
and we can do even better  so to speak,
freeing ourselves for a moment from the will to
live by reading a good novel by hand
or going to the theater says
schopenhauer nowadays we would also
include film in this series
because we
immerse ourselves in it he says every novel is a peep-box in it
one looks at the spasms and conversions of the
frightened human
heart again wonderful thing
so a good thing  ckkasten so don't even
stick a tv on top of that but basically
you could also say they would be looking
there we look into the peep box
and also see the spasms so the
convulsions and the conversions our
emotions of our heart and how
does it work he says well those are
not we ourselves yes so the heroes who
are struggling there we can
lean back and our couple have a drink
that's why we're out of the whole
hustle and bustle and enjoy that now
the hero has to fight but
only works if we identify with the
hero and that's why the quote
all poets are forced to put their heroes
in anxious and embarrassing situations in
order to be able to free them from it again
and that's exactly how the whole thing works to this day
also the hollywood blockbusters
the hero comes more and more tormented and
fights for the princess for the loved one
for the pot of gold  um or wants to save the world
and now it's getting exciting now
says schopenhauer  and every
dramaturgy must then perform a very
important trick
it leads the hero through 1000
difficulties and dangers
down to the bottom as soon as it is reached
the curtain can quickly fall so the
dramaturgy mustafa think and
end everything as soon as the hero has won
because otherwise what would happen otherwise  if that were to
continue now then you would
yes boredom we would see the truth
and that is not possible i would appreciate the
effort of the level beautiful yes very
nice by brecht thank you yes worth brecht
gave us again that
phenomenological shows the effort of the
level
just imagine the
adored enchanting fairytale
mysterious princess and then
you see how they brush their teeth
how they see how they
see how nobody wants him in the supermarket see how romeo and
juliet fight after ten years about 1 over-
boiled egg
the curtain  wolf fall or take
james bond die welt rettet yes that
can be heard in im  come on if he has just
defeated the enemies imagine
that would continue and he has no
enemies and only cuts roses in the garden
yes that would be crazy because then no one
fears him anymore he i always have to
fear tablet
he retires and  he sits in
bantorf info by the open fireplace and gets drunk
every evening with martini that's why nobody
sees the questions have to come up yes and
that's why he
says epic or dramatic
poetry can only ever
strive for a struggle and fight for happiness but never
the permanent roll and complete
representing happiness itself so in conclusion art
music and theater only free us for a
very short time until the curtain
falls again from the will but a person who
now wants to take a longer and more lasting break from
the whole hustle and bustle and
we all want
that has only one chance  is so
schopenhauer he has to say no to the
blind he wants to say no to
life and this saying no is hot  t but
not that he now says the
suicidal person is the ideal-typical
human being and one must take their own life
if the
suicidal person solves the problem not far away from the
denial of the will to be he
by no means gives up the will to live
by destroying the individual appearance of
the  suicides only unite the
individual not the species so and suicides have power but they
only do something to the individual little
villas in their little person made of
lizards but they don’t face the
great refusal of the entire blind
will and we have to do that according to
schopenhauer and  he
says we can only achieve this through asceticism
and meditation voluntary perfect
chastity is the first step in
asceticism which is asceticism is then
further shown in voluntary and intentional
poverty so with schopenhauer it is
exactly like in
buddhism man should not himself  be
guided by externals
he should in de  r meditation
looking for the deep experience of the alh unity
yes the alh unity which eliminates the
difference between one's own and the
foreign individual then it
follows automatically that such a person recognizes
his innermost and
true self
in all beings so this recognition in all beings means of
course  that we completely leave our ego
behind us, for example
if you succeed in recognizing yourself completely in other
beings or in nature as a whole
if you succeed then
you no longer see yourself as an entity as your
own ego yes and that is natural  the
way to nirvana so it must be clear to
us and that's why we also said
it is much more freely confessing that what remains after the complete
abolition of the will is
for everyone in whom the will has
turned and denied nothing
so it's about the way to nirvana
things  and schopenhauer recommends he says
the subway damage and buddhists
celebrate this in madness  he experiences as
the actual enlightenment yes and the
enlightened one overcomes egoism
and leaves his ego completely
behind and how does he do it now and there
schopenhauer's philosophy
of the will to live takes effect again
he recognizes the universality of this
will to live in all living beings and
he knows the principle of how to get into
individuation he recognizes that
basically his modest little ego
that pushes and wriggles and
wants to survive is not really
important in view of the
metaphysical structure that all beings have
this will to live, yes it
is  only small individuation and
recognizes that so he can say because he
sees through the principle of how about individuation
is everything the same to him well well all
beings are the same to him no they are
nirvana experience is always difficult for
us western europeans to understand
but i'll try again now
disagreeing with schopenhauer himself is a
stupid example though  for those of you who
have pets you can
try especially if you look your dog in
the eyes he keeps my eyes
on him he keeps his eyes and if you
look at him and really let him
understand that you are also like me in the
whole  madness look third and in ladenburg quotes
merge with the
dog there you notice that the dog is in the same
mood as you yes so you can
notice that it maybe a bad
example but schopenhauer has
tried something similar before as similar
schopenhauer has tried
visiting greenhouses for hours
into the plants he also talked to the
plants so he was in the greenhouse
in dresden for days the values
tchers have already spoken to him becau
e you talk to the plant
but that's anoth
r anecdote no time at the time and he tr
ed  hanging in the plants
here too feels like hanging in
and also always has animals in free w
ildbahn observed and he says if you do it
long enough then you can see the same manifestation of the will in all
animals in all plants
as
in ourselves so in the whole of nature
you can see that we see in it
so in nature the manifestation of the
will
but if we were to communicate its inner being
, we would best be able to use that
sanskrit formula that
occurs so often in the holy books of the hindu for this purpose
was it that means
you are this living thing so we have to
succeed that we stand in front of the animal
and see  that's me or from the
plant or from nature
as a whole we can also pull ourselves in a forest as
and by ourselves and then we feel at
this level that ultimately I'm
a deception and
the actual reality is that
alone and that we can do it  we
can all do that, says
schopenhauer, that's the reason
for the pity, because some
creatures and
then really guides with humans and animals then says
we feel that the same will to
live is damaged as it ticks in us
and he says even the
metaphysical will to live feels
offended and found in this existence
and that's what it does in us
clear and that's why we
suffer too that's not ethical suffering that's why he
says
this compassion is not based on
religion or dogma
myths upbringing and education but
lies in human nature itself
well i'll sum it up again everything
is driven by life  choose and
for all of us life means
suffering but there are three ways out
art and music so two arts
then of course roman theater today
one would say cinema film and the third that
the only sustainable way out is
actually as cheese chastity fasting
meditation and the search  and the attempt
to go to the anna line height in the
al unit to merge his ego
behind to l  assen
now of course one has to say that
schopenhauer himself has now admitted
that what he has just described what
i have now also described the
logical consequence of his
philosophy of the blind will is the
negation of this if's but he
said that creating only very very few
exceptions  people including master
eckhart and butter the normal person
does who just because
our blind will is so strong we can
hardly get rid of our ego and he himself ladies and
gentlemen was not an ascetic either he
always liked to eat a lot and he
had  although the huge buddha statue in
his apartment was what
every second person
had then as now, but back then he is just him and then
when visitors came and towards the end of his
life he became famous
and more visitors came, he always
showed his pride in the city  and everyone was
astonished, but he himself
meditated a lot and lived critically,
he just always did very well  rn ate and
that's why later the
existentialist alba kam mal wrote
well schopenhauer always asked us
to say no to life
, mostly at a well set
table between the third and fourth
course contemporaries also
criticized schopenhauer how should
one live  you know at that
time because of schopenhauer the
whole asian philosophical area was
first translated
he himself tried to get some young
translations translated and
the whole album king with
schopenhauer loose and schopenhauer himself
says it would be completely unfair if
you criticized him for something like that  that
is not possible at all he says because it is just as
little necessary for the philosopher to be a
saint as it is not necessary for
a great sculptor to be a beautiful person himself
we would accuse michael
angelo that michael angelo had a
tummy just will be his david is
perfect  you can't do that with
ang  measure elo by that and open doesn't
say this year we can measure him by
whether he'll be perfect loves the
theoretical consequences of his
philosophy down to the last detail, but you
have to measure yourself by whether his
philosophy was true and whether it's
helpful and yours says he's the one  case
in particular I am always
accused of being so pessimistic then he
says but now you have to see
what pessimism achieves yes and
then he says
the pessimists the dark
infinite characters we have on the
whole more imaginary but
fewer real accidents  survive
as the keeper and carefree clearly the
pessimist who always thinks from the worst case
and usually doesn't think the
worst case will
come out often has imaginary problems
that don't even occur but when
such a problem arises you're much
better prepared as an optimist  he's
so unreservedly optimistic, says
wittig, he takes much higher risks
and you  knowing
schopenhauer was himself a
hypochondriac he
always took his own glass
with him when going for walks to protect himself from herpes and
other infectious diseases
and when the great cholera broke out in berlin in
1831 mr soffer had bag
and baggage cleared out of the apartment and taken
to the  bring a carriage and is
in town early the same day what is in
the newspaper and
then, after a
stopover in frankfurt, took a new apartment and moved the center of
his life to frankfurt
because frankfurt appeared to him
for a number of reasons that
listed such resistance  and
hegel the great optimistic says
history is constant progress
yes so we are always moving to higher
levels that a constant lifting and
it gets better
the great optimistic only left berlin for a short
time but
then returned and has committed himself
to the  virus infected and is two
months late  ter died and well that may be
the prudence open this year it may
also have been the case but it is
a fact that the optimist he
died and the pessimist
passed on schopenhauer
and also generally says open have made
it clear to us that we all have to die
and  that age of course
also means an increasing weakness of the will
we can live with it much better
, e.g. also the waning of the
sex drive, he says in the aphorisms on the wisdom of
life that also later in the
amount of everyday life was written where it was a
bit more personal yes and that’s where he says
it
too  the slacking of the sex drive
is actually also a small
liberation that raptor could even be
said that the diverse and
endless whims which the
sex drive creates a
constant terrain entertain insane
people that it only becomes completely reasonable after it has
expired
so it only grows
in us as we get older  reason out if times the  Your
drive is finally wearing off
and you also have to
think about it: Yes,
there is another source of pleasure for sexuality.
Venus released you. You will be happy to
choose a place to cheer up at the brook
and so instead of devoting yourself to Venus, the goddess of love
, we should go to the
god of  wine and enjoyment and
we should take refuge in it and
ultimately the great message
from schopenhauer and his legacy is
what he gives us what we ultimately have to
live with the suffering yes so it makes
no sense to ignore it and
this constant search would be completely wrong
Happiness teams fail
and you know nowadays
we have over 20,000 book titles in the German-speaking area
alone where
happiness is in the title, so ten
golden rules of happiness
in five days in a five-day course on happiness or
how do I become happy or so it is
an insane club literature that we
have or 1 i have read luck is
he  learnable
yes therefore results in crazy titles yes and since
we the schopenhauer only shake our heads
schopenhauer says quite happy in the
present no one has ever
felt he unless he was drunk
he also says a happy life is
impossible the highest thing a human being can
achieve  can is a heroic
résumé and with a heroic
résumé ultimately meant that despite all
these pictures in the sixfold suffering
etc. we
still determined to make leaders and
continue living that is very calm that is
a heroic résumé and ultimately
it also has a good message for us at the end
he says in
fact is the conviction that the world,
i.e. man, is something that
shouldn’t really be suitable
to fill us with forbearance towards one another
and that’s because we’re all in
the same boat we are all driven by
this
will and only because
we know that he would treat
each other with leniency and therefore say  t he
should in future worldwide the greeting that we give
each other rather the
greeting formula should be changed yes you
should no longer say my lord or
messi when you address someone or something like that
but made with passion so room
lohrum kompagnon me very well
my fellow zafira mean in this sense
dear fellow sufferers thank you for your
attention
[applause]